Miller cumbersome iron lung gives way
at least in certain circumstances to
industrial and medical progress and playing
a leading role on the industrial end is JJ
Monahan company of Denver where they developed
the portable respirator that's brought freedom
to thousands once permanently confined to the
big boiler type respirator freedom to move
about receive therapy that might alleviate
their ailments and live a little less like
prisoners realization of how their product
will be used is a constant inspiration to
the men and women who fabricate these
life-giving instruments though they've
been in business only six years their artificial
lungs have helped the helpless in 46 countries
from Kenya to Korea these are the pumps the
drive air in and out of the cell enclosing the
patient's chest forcing his stricken lungs to
breathe the cell front is molded from a sheet
of transparent plastic heated to pliability
it's placed in the mold and forced into sea
the plastic is very light like the rest of the
shell to provide maximum mobility to the pace
here it's trimmed to the correct size the
shells come in many sizes to fit anyone from
an infant to a 300-pound adult in addition
the completely snug fit that's absolutely
necessary is further assured by a rubber
seal that fits around the plastic cell front
they make sure every last part is up to
the important job it'll have to perform
for weeks months or years to come for the
people who make this product it's not just
a question of pleasing a customer it's
a matter of keeping the customer alive